>> Will Sentance: Nhưng hãy có ngón tay cái.
Anh đã mất em, em rõ ràng.
Tôi có những lời giải thích.
Mọi người đều thích, tôi tự hào.
Michelle có một, Mike có một.
Mike, hãy đến với bạn trước. >> Mike: Tôi chỉ tự hỏi làm thế nào để
tuyển dụng nếu bạn có các lớp, nếu bạn có một chức năng thời gian chờ đã đặt
được gọi là cần thêm một thời gian. >> Will Sentance: Được rồi, vậy
câu nói của bạn nếu bên trong bản in của tôi Xin chào, tôi sẽ trì hoãn thêm chức năng.
Vì vậy, hãy gọi một hàm khác, không phải là một hàm thực, một mặt tiền cho
tính năng trình duyệt web.
Vâng, được rồi, hãy đến với điều đó.
Michelle. >> Michelle: Câu hỏi của tôi là nếu tôi
đang tích cực thực hiện một cái gì đó trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi?
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời,
nó đi đâu
Chính xác, ngay tại chỗ.
Giả sử tôi có 10.000 bản ghi giao diện điều khiển.
Khi nào thì hàm được phép quay trở lại?
Ngay khi đã sẵn sàng?
Sau năm nhật ký bảng điều khiển đó, sau một vài nhật ký, điều gì sẽ xảy ra nếu tôi
có một chức năng như bạn nói ngồi trên ngăn xếp cuộc gọi trong 300 mili giây?
Hay thậm chí 1000 mili giây?
Khi nào thì printHello được phép bật lại?
Nó sẽ đến một cách ngẫu nhiên?
Có lẽ.
Đó sẽ là một thiết kế ngôn ngữ.
Hãy chắc chắn rằng chúng tôi biết đó là các chức năng mặt tiền của chúng tôi.
Chúng tôi đã có thời gian cố định.
Khi tôi nói mặt tiền, tôi có nghĩa là nó là một mặt tiền, nó là một mặt tiền.
Nó trông giống như một hàm JavaScript, nhưng không phải vậy.
Có vẻ như nó sẽ tạo bối cảnh thực thi,
nó không, không có ý nghĩa đối với chúng ta theo bất kỳ cách nào.
Thay vào đó, nó chỉ quay công việc nền.
Nó là mặt tiền, nó là mặt tiền.
Nó giống như thế giới phương tây đó, Chúa ơi,
những người có khuôn mặt của thế giới phương Tây, ai đã xem chương trình Westworld?
Bạn biết đấy, nơi mà khuôn mặt mở ra Chúa tôi, chết tiệt ghét điều đó.
Tôi thực sự đã xem hai tập đầu tiên và
tập đầu tiên của mùa, với tất cả các ngón tay của tôi như thế này
thông qua bất cứ lúc nào tôi thấy một trong những người đó khuôn mặt của họ mở ra.
Và nó đã xảy ra.
Tôi đã xem một chút nội dung đó và tôi đã không xem nó kể từ đó.
Tôi không thích chương trình này nữa.
Tôi không muốn nhìn thấy những khuôn mặt đang mở ra, nhưng nó là như thế này.
Nó giống như một mặt tiền. Dành cho những bạn chưa xem
Westworld, đó là phiên bản giả vờ của người hoặc có thể không.
Có lẽ chúng cũng thật như chúng ta.
Nhưng ban đầu chúng được tạo ra một cách máy móc,
nghĩa là đằng sau lớp da là những thứ máy móc.
Và tất cả chúng ta đều biết rằng con người thấy điều đó rất, rất rùng rợn.
Vâng, đó là những gì setTimeout giống như.
Nó là một mặt tiền cho chức năng bên ngoài chính nó.
Nó không có thật, nó không phải là JavaScript thuần túy.
Nó giả vờ.
Của bạn đây.
Tôi ghét loại suy, đó là lý do tại sao tôi ghét loại suy.
Tốt, vì vậy chúng tôi đang tương tác với một thế giới bên ngoài JavaScript.
Chúng tôi cần các quy tắc.
Chúng tôi cần các quy tắc nghiêm ngặt về cách chúng tôi sẽ tương tác với nó.
Vì vậy, chúng ta sẽ thấy mã này ở đây để xác định một loạt các tình huống
sẽ cho biết các quy tắc của chúng tôi phải là gì.
Vì vậy, chúng ta bắt đầu, từng dòng một, chúng ta sẽ xem qua mã của chúng ta.
Và sau đó, chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu lập trình cặp.
Và sau đó chúng ta sẽ thấy một giải pháp hoàn toàn mới mà mọi người đều yêu thích
không sử dụng mô hình này.